what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel so
today i wanted to talk about um i have
my first
i have my first hater and i'm really
excited about it like honestly
um
i always said
that the day that i have like
accounts that hate follow me so to speak
like that'll be the day i made it
i don't know man okay
but the the person that i saw i forgot
what the account is called but
small like tiny little account it's like
a black pill channel and it said
i don't know i'm just like walking
around
this house is big but basically actually
i'm gonna go in the closet because it's
really echoey and i think you'll be able
to hear me better
but basically this guy um
was saying that i pander to
black pill red pill pick up like i just
say whatever
i agree with and i disagree with so um
i thought i'd make this video just to
like
clarify my like thoughts on the red pill
the black pill
and
um
and the like pickup community
so all right this is this is the way i
see it okay
i think red pill doesn't
talk about how much looks play into a
factor
um
they they just say like
oh if you do all the right things and
chase your bag
like at the end of it you'll be a high
value man
but i've seen guys that aren't
attractive um
that have a lot of money that really
still can't get girls because they don't
have like
i don't know like that leadership
qualities and like those i don't know
game so to speak
um
so yeah that's what i like about
blackpill is blackpill i think they're
like the wheat waffles channel i think
that his like rating system is actually
like pretty accurate and i think it's
really interesting to listen to
um
but
the black pill a lot of times i think
they just focus on the problem and not a
solution
so
you know if you're born a sub five like
there's nothing you can really do about
where you're born so you can either
complain about it or do the best with
what you got
which i think that red pill kind of like
fakes a solution sometimes like
sometimes i don't think
that those guys really get girls like
they say they do and i think a lot of
times red pill is kind of like
fake it till you make it type stuff
which would be fine if they're a little
bit more honest about it
um just my feeling right like i have no
proof i can't possibly say if they get
girls they don't it's just like a vibe
as a girl
then we get to the pickup so pick up
genuinely those guys have so much proof
of them getting girls that
i genuinely think they're experts like
in their craft of just like getting
females and i think a lot of times they
offer the most solutions to black pill
and red pill
um
like they offer the most solutions that
that seem like tangible and seem like
they would work
but the way i see it i think you're born
like a one to ten in terms of like how
attractive you are and i think
that you can go up or down like maybe
one or two points but you can't
like go up four or five points if that
makes sense unless you're like an
extreme but like most people aren't
extremes like they'll always use the
extreme millionaires and billionaires
but that's such a small subset of the
population like most guys if they
increase their income it's going to be
like 10k
you know 20k you know which is still
significant but like that's that's not
the norm
um
i'm sorry someone's like yelling in this
house
but i don't know if that clarified like
my position on this stuff um and i'm
really
not super quick to give advice like a
lot of people have been asking like for
like my thoughts on certain things and
it's tough for me to say
to give like set in stone advice to guys
because i really want to study it more
before
i start giving you guys my thoughts
because i really want to like test my
thoughts and make sure
that they're credible you know before i
start
giving you guys like different advice
and like what i would do so i don't know
i hope that clarifies
my thought i just literally thought it
was so funny today
the internet is so weird like oh my gosh
it's so weird but let me know what you
guys think in the comments um don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell and i will talk
to you guys next time